hey guys there is much the 15th my
name's Jess and here's what matters in
gaming today Microsoft has announced
that the gears of war for multiplayer
beta will begin on Xbox one studying
April 18 to get into the beta on that
date you'll need to have played gears of
war Ultimate Edition on xbox one or PC
by April 11 after that point microsoft
will send out the first batch of codes
to a selection of users before extending
access to all qualifying xbox live gold
members on april 20 for the beta will be
playable for room a 1 if you're stuck on
that qualifying remark Microsoft didn't
explain what they meant by it at the
time of writing the publisher are yet to
drop any details about what will be
included in the fader a YouTube user has
found potential future DLC locations in
the division the user who goes by Chas
has published a 4 minute video which
shows off how players can explore
sectioned off areas of the shooter one
such location is jewett Park which is
clearly unfinished and filled with bugs
the Central Park area is also currently
under developed with only a few touches
here and there these could be abandoned
works or Ubisoft may be intending to
populate them in future DLC if your
super keen to see them in their current
state you can follow the videos guide to
getting into the area I'll warn you
though it's pretty complicated in gaming
lawsuit News Lindsay Lohan vs. grand
theft auto 5 will be going ahead after
she claimed a character in the game with
an unequivocal reference to her although
take-two interactive maintains that
there is no reference and Lohan is doing
for publicity purposes a New York
Supreme Court judge has refused to throw
the case out Judge John Kennedy ruled
that quote she can't rely upon the
defendants documents aiming to show the
images in question don't show low end
Aztec to have been providing their own
images for comparison she also ruled
that the statute of limitations is not
applicable in this case so take tues
claim that Lohan brought the lawsuit too
late was also dismissed if all that
sounds insane and complicated to you
you'll probably enjoy this tweet from
Ned Luke who plays Michael de Santa in
GTA 5 where he says it's a stretch but
maybe there's a resemblance hashtag
lindsey is nuts in the gaming side of
things rakta have just released a new
GTA online update which includes new car
customization options tattoo designs
hairstyles and the new adversary mode
called sumo which sounds a lot like sumo
wrestling but with cars we shall let me
know down in that comment box what you
think of the lawsuit and head to
gamespot where we've got stories on the
division sales and warcraft breeze
update that is everything I have for you
today but let me know what mattered to
you and I will see you again tomorrow